previously on model lifestyle so I just
arrived in South Africa captain and
there's a water problem here what is
left people win today I don't want that
nothing why do you want is water I don't
get DNZ I don't care cope or whatever
yeah my model apartment for the next two
months something dangerous they happen
here somebody died over here I noticed
all the homeless people anyway I finally
arrived at my agency on my way back I
saw yet another crime scene all day I
decided to go check out a church near
the model apartment it is called Life
Church after the service the pastor
invited me to go with him to the poor
area of Cape Town to see the project
that they have there to help the kids
who are
the modeling season in Cape Town seemed
to have stopped and I'm not getting any
work but instead of just sitting and
waiting I decided to use the time to
explore Cape Town and I went everywhere
[Music]
finally just as I thought that the
modelling season in Cape Town will be
bad I got my first casting but I was not
ready for what I was about to experience
i if this is your first time on my
channel subscribe and hit the bell so
you won't miss the next video
[Music]
right now I'm seeing a few models that
are waiting outside which means that
there are probably a lot of models that
are waiting inside hey Tom caffee and I
was right look at this and I thought I
was early so at all the castings in Cape
Town you have to write down your name
and then you can see on a piece of paper
then you get a number then the waiting
starts so many models here on the
opinion we models have a certain same
hurry-up-and-wait
you say this because agencies studios
and clients they always want us to be on
time then they make us wait
[Music]
my number is 122 which is insane because
I came here 20 minutes early but still
121 models got here before me which
means there are a lot of models in town
fighting for jobs news came that Cape
Town's water will be cut off so many
clients decided not to do photo shoots
in Cape Town which means there are too
many models in town and not enough jobs
this is not looking good
[Music]
unfortunately they did not allow me to
take more of years inside the caste but
after two hours unfinished
[Music]
a few days went by and I'm on the way to
my second cat
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I added my name to a list and then they
asked me to turn off my camera so
another week he's gone and I only got
two castings it is not looking great
[Music]
the time went on gas things stopped but
I would not let this get me down in the
meantime I would work out every day
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and every day I would go out somewhere
in Cape Town to get some fresh air
[Music]
if you come to Cape Town for modeling
you can get in my city bus and it will
take you anywhere you want to go but
you're ready to wait a long time in
off-peak periods
[Music]
[Music]
today I decided to go to Camden Bay this
is one of the best things about modeling
in Capeside it is that you can go down
to the beach whenever you have some free
tests now
Kam's Bay is a famous beach in South
Africa because of its beautiful white
sandy beach and it's tropical palm trees
and it's got this beautiful mountain
backdrop
it has a great cafe culture right on the
beach so you can grab a bite to eat or a
cocktail whenever you feel like it
[Music]
so Cape Town is almost perfect the only
problem is that the water is cold as the
only thing I would change that and the
crime and the corruption but as time
went by I started to think that I should
cut this trip short there is no work in
Cape Town time flew by and then my
mother agency organised a photo shoot
for me but it was one and a half hour
away from kids huh hey so we're on the
way to believe store I'm doing a photo
shoot there and I'm here with my mother
from Cape Town Mary in the back has the
opportunity give me a lift to Billy's
door and I'm here with Darren a really
cool guy as well so
[Music]
certain Saddam domain
that's Afrikaans accent if you're
actually English this trip with mother
Mary and Darrin was funding and we saw a
lot of things on the road we even saw
baboons made a quick stop by the prison
where the famous in Nelson Mandela was
held up
[Music]
turn left at the end of this road and be
in French French okay tumors the people
who still stay here are they French or
are they mixed South Africans and French
yeah it's mixed but you do have quite a
few French families who are still
farmers from the olden days that have
become assimilated so that's where you
get the surnames like Villa air which is
from the from France the only call it
very Villiers the olerude love a shame
level scully de cassis do plac'd yeah
those are all French words here du toit
wah yeah Victor tois some of the white
people in South Africa I've stayed here
for a long time their ancestors arrived
here in the 1600s but now sadly our
corrupt government started to move
forward with a new law which allows land
expropriation without any compensation
which is basically stealing so right now
Nikita and I are actually in the process
of looking to emigrate to another
country
[Music]
[Music]
we also pass by the dear voters that the
largest dear voters dump this is the
water supply of Cape Town and there is
no water is insane okay
EVs neoteny
nothing left
you see there's no water left yeah
anyway finally we arrived at the leaders
door and we started the photo shoot I
[Music]
[Music]
noticed that this photographer does not
take a lot of photos to get his shots he
takes only a few photos at the start
just to adjust the camera settings then
when it's ready he takes only 10 to 20
shots so my poses needed to be spot-on
his name is Milan Khurana
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the job finished quickly and it was a
great day we were on the road back to
Cape Town again and as we drove back
home I started to miss Nikita and then
my responsibilities as a hospital to
kick in and I was wondering if it really
is a good idea to stay here in Cape Town
longer because now that I've seen the
water crisis and all the models fighting
to survive the low amount of castings
and clients I can't control any of it
but I do have a wife to take care of and
and Belle's need to be paid
[Music]
[Applause]
but I think I know what to do
[Music]
by if this is your first time on my
channel subscribe and hit the bell so
you won't miss the next video
[Music]
you